The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's
start, so last lecture,
we were talking about elasticity
as an example of a field
theory-- statistical
field theory.
And I ended the class by not
giving a very good answer
for a question was asked.
So let's go back and revisit it.
So the idea that we
had was that maybe we
have some kind of a lattice.
And we make a
distortion through a set
of vectors in however many
dimensional space we are.
And in the continuum
format, we basically
regarded this u as being an
average over some neighborhood.
But before going to do that,
we said that the energy cost
of the distortion at the
quadratic level-- of course,
we can expand to go
to a higher level--
was the sum over all
pairs of positions,
all pairs of components,
alpha and beta data
running from one to
a higher whatever
the dimensionality of space
is u alpha at r or u beta
at r prime.
The components alphabet beta
of this vector u at these two
different locations-- let's
say r and r prime here.
And then there was some
kind of an object that
correlated the changes here
and here maybe obtained
as a second derivative
of a potential energy
as a function of the
entirety of the coordinates.
And this in principle
or a general function
of all of these
distortions depends
on all pairs of variables.
But then we said that because
we are dealing with a lattice
and one pair of
coordinates in the lattice
is the same as another
pair of coordinates
that have the same spatial
orientations that this function
merely is a function
of the separation
r minus r prime,
which of course can
be a vector in this lattice.
And the fact that
it has this form
then allows us to simplify
this quadratic form
rather than be a sum over
pairs and squared, if you like,
into a sum over one
coordinate which
is the wave vector obtained
by Fourier transform.
So once we Fourier
transform, that V
can be written as a sum over
just one set of K vectors,
of course appropriately
discretized depending
on the overall
size of the system
and confined to a [INAUDIBLE]
zone that is determined
by the type of wavelengths
that lattice structure allows.
And
Then this becomes
your alpha tilde.
The Fourier
transform's evaluated
at K and the other point, which
is minus K that if I write it
again as K is really this.
And this entity, once
we Fourier transform it,
becomes a function of
the wave number K. Now,
there is one statement
that is correct,
which is that if I have to take
the whole lattice and move it,
then essentially there
would be no cost.
And moving the
entire lattice only
changes the Fourier component
that corresponds to K
equals to 0-- translation
of everything.
So you know for sure that this
K alpha beta at K equals to 0
has to be 0.
Now, we did a little bit
more than that, then.
We said, let's look not only at
K equals to 0, but for small k.
And then for small
k, we are allowed
to make an expansion of this.
And this is the
expansion K squared,
K to the fourth,
et cetera, that we
hope to terminate at
low values of K. Now,
that itself is an assumption.
That's part of the
locality that i
stated that I can make an
expansion as a function of K.
After all, let's
say K to the 1/2
is a function that goes
to 0 at K equals to 0.
But it is non analytic.
Turns out that in order to
generate that kind of non
analyticity in
this, this function
in real as a function
of separation
should decay very slow.
Sometimes something like
a Coulomb interaction
that is very long
range will give you
that kind of singularity.
But things that are
really just interacting
within some neighborhood or
even if they are long range,
if the action falls of
sufficiently rapidly--
and that's one of the things
that we will discuss later
on-- precisely what
kind of potential
allow you to make
an expansion that
is analytical in powers
of k and hence consistent
with this idea of locality.
Let's also ignore
cases where you
don't have inversion symmetry.
So we don't need to start
and worry about anything
that is linear in K. So the
first thing that I can appear
is quadratic in K.
Now, when we have things
that are quadratic in K,
I have to make an
object that has
two indices-- alpha and beta.
And, well, how can I do that?
Well, the kinds of things
that I mentioned last time, we
could a term that is K squared.
And then we have a
delta alpha beta.
If I insert that over
here, what do I get?
I get K squared delta alpha beta
will give me U tilde squared.
So that's the term that is in
an isotropic solid identified
with the shear modulus.
Again, if the
system is isotropic,
I don't know any distance
apart from any other distance,
any direction, any
other direction.
I can still make another
tensor between this
is alpha and beta by
multiplying k alpha and k beta.
If I then multiply
this with this,
I will get K.U-- the
dot product squared.
So that's the other term
that in an isotropic solid
was identified with
nu plus lambda over 2.
Now, as long as any direction
for K in this lattice
is the same, those are
really the only terms
that you can write down.
But suppose that your
system was unisotropic,
such as for example a
rectangular lattice.
Or let's imagine we put
a whole bunch of coins
here to emphasize that
rather than something
like a square lattice,
we have something
that is very rectangular.
In this case, we can see
that the x and y directions
are not the same.
And there is no reason why
this K squared here could not
have been separately kx
squared plus some other number
ky squared.
And hence, the type of
elasticity that you would have
would no longer depend
on just two numbers.
But, say, over here with three,
in fact there would be more.
And precisely how many
independent elastic constants
are given depend on the point
group symmetry-- the way
that your lattice is
structured over here.
But that's another story that
I don't want to get into.
But last time, I
was rather careless
and I said that just rotational
symmetry will give you
this k squared, k alpha, k beta.
I have to be more
precise about that.
So this is what's happened.
Now, given that you have
an isotropic material,
then the conclusion is
that the potential energy
will have two types of terms.
There is the type
of term that goes
with k squared u tilde squared.
And then there's a
type of term that
goes with u plus lambda over 2k
tilde k times u tilde squared.
Now you can see that
immediately there
is a distinction between
two types of distortion.
Because if I select
my wave vector K here,
any distortion that
is orthogonal to that
then will not get the
contribution from this.
And so the cost of those so
called transverse distortions
only come from u.
Whereas if I make a
distortion that is along k,
it will get contribution
from both of those two terms.
And hence, the cost of those
longitudinal distortions
would be different.
So when we go back
to our story of how
does the frequency depend
on a whole bunch of ks,
you can see that when
we go to the small k
limit in an isotropic
material, it
you've established that there
will be longitudinal mode.
And we'll some kind of
longitudinal sound velocity.
And in three
dimensions, there will
be two branches of the
transverse mode that
fall on top of each-other.
As I said, once you go
to further larger K,
then you can include all
kinds of other things.
In fact, the types of
things that you can include
at fourth order,
sixth order, et cetera
again are constraints
somewhat by the symmetry.
But their number proliferates.
And eventually you get
all kinds of things
that could potentially describe
how these modes depend.
And those things are
dependent on your potential
I don't know too much about.
And why was this relevant
to what we were discussing?
We said that basically, once
you go to some temperature other
than zero, you start putting
energy into the modes.
And how far in frequency you
can go given your temperature,
typically, the maximum frequency
at the particular temperature
is of the order of kt over hr.
So that if you are at
very high temperature,
all of the r1 equals [INAUDIBLE]
and all of the vibrations
are relevant.
But if you go to
low temperatures,
eventually you hit
the regime where
only these long wavelength, low
frequency modes are excited.
And your heat
capacity was really
proportional to how
many modes are excited.
And from here, you
can see since omega
goes like T, either the
case, for longitudinal
or the k for
transverse has to be
proportional to T the maximum 1.
Larger values of
k would correspond
to frequencies that
are not excited.
So all of the nodes
that are down here
are going to be excited.
How many of them are there?
Up to from 0 to
this k max that is
of the order of kt over h
bar and some sound velocity.
So you would say that
the heat capacity which
is proportional to the number of
oscillators that you can have,
you kt-- kb per oscillator.
The number of oscillators
was roughly volume
times kt h bar v, cubed if
you are in three dimensions.
You saw that it was
one in one dimension.
So in general, it will
be something like d.
Of course, here, I was kind
of not very precise because I
really have to separate
out the contribution
of longitudinal modes and
transverse modes, et cetera.
So ultimately, the
amplitude that I have
will depend on a
whole bunch of things.
But the functional form is
this universal t to the d.
So the lesson that we would like
to get from this simple, well
known example is
that sometimes you
get results that are
independent in form
for very different materials.
I will use the
term universality.
And the origin of
that universality
is because we are
dealing with phenomena
that involve
collective behavior.
As k becomes small, you're
dealing with large wavelengths
encompassing the
collective motion of lots
of things that are
vibrating together.
And so this kind of
statistical averaging
over lots of things that are
collectively working together
allows a lot of the details
to in some sense be washed out
and gives you a
universal form just
like adding random variables
will give you a Gaussian if you
add sufficient many
of them together.
It's that kind of phenomenon.
Typically, we will be
dealing with these kinds
of relationships
between quantities
that have dimensions.
Heat capacity has dimensions.
Temperature has dimensions.
So the amplitude
will have to have
things that have dimensions
that come from the material
that you are dealing with.
So the thing that is
universal is typically
the exponents that appear
in these functional forms.
So those are the kinds
of things that we
would like to capture
in different contexts.
Now, as I said,
this was supposed
to be just an illustration
of the typical approach.
The phenomenon that
we will be grappling
with for a large
part of this course
has to do with
face transactions.
And again, this is
a manifest result
of having interaction among
degrees of freedom that
causes them to collectively
behave separately differently
from how a single
individual would behave.
And the example
that we discussed
in the previous
course and is familiar
is of course that of
ice, water, steam.
So here, we can look
at things from two
different perspectives.
One perspective, let's say
we start by-- actually,
let's start with the
perspective in which I show you
pressure and temperature.
And as a function of
pressure and temperature,
low temperatures
and high pressures
would respond to having
some kind of a-- actually,
let me not incur
the wrath of people
who know the slopes of
these curves precisely.
So there is at low
temperatures, you have ice.
And then the more
interesting part
is that you have at high
temperatures and low pressures
gas.
And then at
immediate values, you
have, of course, the liquid.
And the other perspective
to look at this
is to look at isoterms of
the system for pressure
versus velocity.
So basically, what I'm doing is
I'm staking at some temperature
and calculating the behavior
along that isoterm of how
pressure and volume of
the system are related.
So then you are far
out to the right,
you'll have behavior that is
releasing of an ideal gas.
You have PV be proportional
to the number of particles
in temperature.
As you lower the
temperatures and you
hit this critical isoterm at
TC, the shape of the curve
gets modified to
something like this.
And if you're looking
at things at isoterms
at an even lower temperature,
you encounter a discontinuity.
And that discontinuity
is manifested
in a coexistent interval
between the liquid and gas.
So isoterms for T
and less than TC
has this characteristic form.
So here, I have not bothered
to go along the way down
to the case of the solid.
Because our focus is going
to be mostly as to what
happens at this critical
point-- TC and TC,
where the distinction between
liquid and gas disappears.
So there is here the
first case of a transition
between different
types of material
that is manifested here,
the solid line indicating
a discontinuity in various
thermodynamic properties.
Discontinuity here
being, say, the density
as a function of pressure.
Rather than having a nice
curve, you have a discontinuity.
In these curves, isoterms
are suddenly discontinuous.
And the question that we
posed last time last semester
was that essentially,
all the properties
of the system, the
thermodynamic properties, I
should be able to obtain
through the partition function,
log of the partition function,
which involves an integral,
let's say, over all
of the coordinates
and momenta of some
kind of energy.
And this energy in
the part about momenta
is not particularly important.
Let's just get rid of that.
And the part about
the coordinates
involves some kind of
potential interaction
between pairs of particles.
That is not that difficult.
Maybe particles are slightly
attracted to each other
when they're close enough.
And they have a hard core.
But somehow, after I do this
calculation bunch of integrals,
all of them are
perfectly well behaved.
There is no divergence.
As
The range of
integration goes to zero
and infinity, I get
this discontinuity.
And the question
of how that appears
is something that clearly is
a consequence of interactions.
If we didn't have
interactions, we
would have ideal gas behavior.
And maybe this place is
really a better place
to go and try to
figure out what's
going on than any other
place in the phase diagram.
The reason for that is in
the vicinity of this point,
we can see that the difference
between liquid and gas
is gradually disappearing.
So in some sense, we
have a small parameter.
There's some small
difference that appears here.
And so maybe the idea that
we can start with some phase
that we understand fully
and then perturb it
and see how the singularity
appears is a good idea.
I will justify for you
why that's the case
and maybe why we can even
construct a statistical field
theory here.
But the reason it
is also interesting
is that there is a lot of
experimental evidence as to why
you should be doing this.
We discussed the phase diagrams.
And we noticed that a
interesting feature of these
phase diagrams is that below TC
when the liquid and gas first
manifest themselves
as different phases ,
there is a coexistence interval.
And this coexistence interval
is bounded on two sides
by the gas and liquid volumes
or alternatively densities.
Now, the interesting
experimental fact
is that when you go and observe
the shape of this curve,
for the whole bunch of
different gases-- here,
you have neon, argon, krypton,
xenon, oxygen, carbon dioxide,
methane, things that
are very different--
and scale them appropriately so
that all of the vertical axes
comes to one.
So you divide P by PC.
You appropriately normalize
the horizontal axis
so the maximum is at 1.
You see that all of the
curves you get from very, very
different systems after you
just do this simple scaling
fall right on top of each-other.
Now, clearly something like
carbon dioxide and neon,
they have very different
inter atomic potentials
that I have to put
in this calculation.
Yet despite that,
there has emerged
some kind of a universal law.
And so I should be
able to describe that.
Why is that happening?
Now I'll try to convince
you that what I need to do
is similar to what I did there.
I need to construct a
statistical field theory.
But we said that
statistical field theories
rely on averaging
over many things.
So why is that justified
in this context?
So there is a phenomenon
called critical opalescence.
Let's look at it here.
Also, this serves to show
something that people sometimes
don't believe, which is that
since our experience comes
from no pressures, where we cool
the gas and it goes to a liquid
or heat it and
liquid goes to a gas
and know that these
are different things,
it's kind of-- they
find it hard to believe
that if I repeat the same
thing at high pressure,
there is no difference
between liquid and gas.
They are really the same thing.
And so this is an
experiment that
is done going more or
less around here where
the critical point is.
And you start initially at
the low temperatures side
where you can see that at
the bottom of your wire,
you have a liquid.
And a meniscus separates
it nicely from a gas.
As you heat it up, you approach
the critical temperature.
Well, the liquid expands
and keeps going up.
And once you hit TC and beyond,
that well, one is the liquid
and which one's the gas?
You can't tell the
difference anymore, right?
There is a variation in density.
Because of gravity, there's
more density down here up there.
OK, now what happens when
we start to cool this?
Ah, what happened?
That's called
critical opalescence.
You can't see through that.
And why?
Because there are all
of these fluctuations
that you can now see.
Right at TC when the
thing became black,
there were so many fluctuations
covering so different length
scales that light
could not get through.
But now gradually, the
size of the fluctuations
which exists both in the
liquid and in the gas
are becoming small but
still quite visible.
So clearly, despite the
fact that whatever atoms
and molecules you have over
here have very short range
interactions, somehow in
the vicinity of this point,
they decided to move
together and have
these collective fluctuations.
So that's why we should be able
to do a statistical theory.
And that's why there is a hope
that once we have done that,
because the important
fluctuations are covering
so many large numbers
of atoms or molecules,
we should be able to explain
what's going on over here.
So that's the task
that we set ourselves.
Anything about this
before I close the video?
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There are
Gaussians that when rescaled,
their plots still
comply to that?
PROFESSOR: No.
No.
In the vacinity-- so maybe
the range of the things
that collapse on top
of each-other is small.
Maybe it is so
small that you have
to do things at low
pressure differences
in order to see that.
But as far as we
know, if you have
sufficient high
resolution, everything
will collapse on top
of that [INAUDIBLE].
And what is more interesting
than that-- that is not
confined to gases.
If I had done an
experiment that involved
mixing some protein that has a
dense phase and a dilute phase
and I went to the
point where there
is a separation between dense
and dilute and I plotted that,
that would also fall exactly
on top of this [INAUDIBLE].
So it's not even gases.
It's everything.
And so-- so yes?
AUDIENCE: I heard
you built a system
where some [INAUDIBLE] damages?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And we will discuss those too.
AUDIENCE: And the
exponents will change?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So it's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You may
anticipate from that T
to the D over there,
the dimension is
an important point, yes.
OK?
Anything else?
All right.
I'm going to rather
than construct
this theory, this
statistical filter
for the case of this
liquid gas system,
I'm going to do it for the
case of the ferromagnet
just to emphasize this fact
that this result, this set
of results spans much more
than simple liquid gas
phenomena-- a lot of different
things-- and secondly,
because writing it for
the case of ferromagnet
is much simpler because
of the inherent symmetries
that I will describe
to you shortly.
So what is the phenomenon
that I would like to describe?
What's the phase
transition in the case
of the ferromagnet
like a piece of iron?
Where one axis that is always of
interest to us is temperature.
And if I have a piece of iron or
nickel or some other material,
out here at high temperatures,
it is a paramagnet.
And there is a
critical temperature TC
below which it becomes
a ferromagnet, which
means that it has some
permanent magnetization.
And actually, the reason
I drew the second axis is
that a very nice way to
examine the discontinuities
is to put an external magnetic
field and see what happens.
Because if you put an
external magnetic field
like you put your piece of
magnet enclosed in some parent
[INAUDIBLE] loop so
that you have field
in one direction or
the other direction,
then as you change
this [INAUDIBLE]
of the field on the
high temperature side,
what you'll find is that if I
plot where the magnetization is
pointing, well, if you put
the magnetic field on top
of a paramagnet,
it also magnetizes.
It does pull in the
direction of the field.
The amount of
magnetization that you
have in the system when you are
on the high temperatures side
looks something like this.
At very high fields,
all of your spins
are aligned with the field.
As you low the field because
of entropy and thermal
fluctuations, they
start to move around.
They have too much
fluctuation when
you're in the phase
that is a paramagment.
And it then when
the field goes to 0,
the magnetization
reverses itself.
And you will get a
structure such as this.
So this is the behavioral
of magnetization
as a function of the
field if you go along
the path such as this which
corresponds to the paramagnet.
Now, what happens if
I do the same thing
but I do it along a
looped route such as here?
So again, when you are out
here at high magnetic field,
not much happens.
But when you hit 0, then
you have a piece of magnet.
It has some magnetization.
So basically, it goes to
some particular value.
There is hysteresis.
So let's imagine that you
start with a system down here
and then reduce
the magnetic field.
And you would be getting
a curve such as this.
So in some sense,
right at H equals to 0
when you are 4T less than
TC, there is a discontinuity.
You don't know whether you are
one side or the other side.
And in fact, these curves are
really the same as the isoterms
that we had for the
liquid gas system
if I were to turn them
around by 90 degrees.
The paramagnetic curve looks
very much topologically
like what we have for their
isoterm at high temperatures
where the discontinuity
that we have
for the magnetization
of the ferromagnet
looks like the isoterm that we
would have at low temperatures.
And indeed,
separating these two,
there will be some kind
of a critical isoterm.
So if I were to go
exactly down here,
you see what I would
get is a curve that
is kind of like this-- comes
and hogs the vertical axis
and then does that,
which is in the sense
that we were discussing
before identical to the curve
that you have for the isoterm
of the liquid gas coexistence.
What do I mean?
I could do the same
type of collapse of data
that I showed you
before that I was
doing for the coexistence curve.
I can do that for these
inverted coexistence curves.
I can do the same collapse
for this critical isoterm
of the ferromagnet.
And it would fall on top
of the critical isoterm
that I would have for neon,
argon, krypton, anything else.
So that is that kind of
overall universality.
Now-- yes?
AUDIENCE: In this
[INAUDIBLE], why didn't you
draw the full loop
of hysteresis?
PROFESSOR: Because I'm
interested at this point
with equilibrium phenomena.
Hysteresis is a non
equilibrium thing.
So depending on how rapid you
cool things or not cool things,
you will get larger curves--
larger hysteresis curves.
AUDIENCE: So what
would it have been
if we had high-- wasn't
[INAUDIBLE] fields
that were slowly reduce it to 0?
And then go a little
bit beyond and then
just stay in that
state for a long time?
Will the--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
If you wait sufficiently
long time, which
is the definition
of equilibrium,
you would follow the
curve that I have drawn.
There would be-- so the
size of the hysteresis loop
will go down as the amount
of time that you wait.
Except that in
order to see this,
you may have to wait longer
than the age of the universe.
I don't know.
But in principle, that's
what's going to happen.
AUDIENCE: I have
a question here.
PROFESSOR: Yes
AUDIENCE: When you create
the flat line for temperature
below the critical one--
PROFESSOR: Yes
AUDIENCE: --are you
essentially doing
sort of a Maxwell
construction again?
Or is that too
much even for this?
PROFESSOR: No.
I mean, I haven't done
any theoretical work.
At this point, I'm just
giving you observation.
Once we start to
give theory, there
is a type of theory
for the magnet that
is the analog of
Maxwell's construction
that you would do for the
case of the liquid gas.
Indeed, you will have that
as the first problem set.
So you can figure
it out for yourself.
Anything else?
OK.
So I kind of emphasized
that functional forms
are the things
that are universal.
And so in the context
of the magnet,
it is more clear
how to characterize
these functional forms.
So one of the things
that we have over here
is that if I plot the true
equilibrium magnetization
as a function of temperature
for fields that are 0--
so H equals to 0.
If I start along
the 0 field line,
then all the way up
to TC, magnetization
at high temperatures
is of course 0.
You're dealing
with a paramagnet.
By definition, it
has no magnetization.
When you go below
TC, you'll have
a system that is
spontaneously magnetized.
Again, exactly
what that means is
it needs a little
bit of clarification.
Because it does depend on
the direction of your field.
The magnitude of
it is well defined.
If I go from H to
minus H, the sine of it
could potentially change.
But the magnitude has
a form such as this.
It is again very
similar, if you like,
to half of that
co existence curve
that we had for the liquid gas.
And we look at the behavior
that you have in this vicinity.
And we find that is
well-described by a power law.
So we say that M as T goes
to TC for H equals to 0
is characterized or is
proportional to TC minus T
to an exponent that is
given the symbol beta.
Now, sometimes you can't
write this as TC minus T
to the-- make it dimension.
It doesn't matter.
It's the same exponent.
Sometimes in order not to have
to write all of this thing
again and again, you
call this small T.
It's just that
reduced temperature
from the critical point.
And so basically, what we
have is that T to the beta
characterizes the singularity
of the coexistence line,
the magnetization [INAUDIBLE].
Now, rather then sitting
at H equals to 0,
I could have sat exactly
at T equals to TC
and merely H. So essentially,
this is the curve.
I say that T equals to TC.
This is the blue curve.
We see that new blue has this
characteristic form that it
also comes to 0 not linearly.
So there is an exponent
that characterizes that.
that again is typically
written as 1 over delta.
So you can see that if I go
back to the critical isoterm
of the liquid gas system.
For the liquid gas system,
I would conclude that, say,
delta v goes like delta P
to the power of delta or one
goes with the other to
the power of 1 if it.
So essentially, the
shapes of these two things
are very much
related, characterized
by these two exponents.
What else?
Another thing that we can
certainly measure for a magnet
is the susceptibility.
So chi-- let's measure it
as a function of temperature
but for field equal to 0.
So basically, I sit eventually
at the equals to TC.
But I put on a
small magnetic field
and see how the
magnetization changes.
You can see that as
long as I am above TC
in the paramagnetic phase, there
is a linear relationship here.
Chi is proportional to H.
But the proportionality here
is the susceptibility.
As I get closer to C, that
susceptibility diverges.
OK, so chi is
proportional to T diverges
with an exponent that
is indicated by gamma.
Actually, let me be a
little bit more precise.
So what I have said is that
if I plot the susceptibility
as a function of temperature
at TC, it diverges.
I could also calculate something
similar to that below TC.
Below TC, it is
true that I already
have some magnetization.
But if I put on
a magnetic field,
the magnetization will go up.
And I can define
the slope of that
as being the
susceptibility below TC.
And again, as I
approach TC from below,
that susceptibility
also diverges.
So there is a susceptibility
that comes like this.
So you would say, OK.
There's a susceptibility above.
And there is a
susceptibility below.
And maybe they diverge
with different exponents.
at this point, we don't know.
Yes or no.
We will show shortly that
indeed the two gammas are really
the same and using one exponent
is sufficient for that story.
And analog of susceptibility
in the case of the liquid gas
would be the compressibility.
And the compressibility
is related somehow
to the inverse of
these PV curve slopes.
We know that the sign of it has
to be negative for stability.
But right on the
critical isoterm,
you see that this slope goes
to 0 or its inverse diverges.
So there is, again, the same
exponent gamma for some magnets
also describes that divergence.
Susceptibility is an example
of a response function.
You perturb the system
and see how it responds.
Another response
function that we've
seen is the heat capacity where
you put heat into this system
or you try to change
the temperature
and see how the heat
energy is modified.
And again, we
experimentally observe.
We already saw
something like this
when we were discussing
the super fluid
transition, the lambda
transition-- that the heat
capacity as a function of
temperature at some transition
temperatures happens to diverge.
And in principle,
one can again look
at the two sides
of the transition
and characterize them by
divergences that are typically
indicated by the exponent alpha.
Again, you will see
that there are reasons
why there is only one
exponent [INAUDIBLE].
So this is essentially
the only part
where there is some
zoology involved.
You have to remember
and learn where
the different
exponents come from.
The rest of it, I hope, is
very logical-- but which
one is alpha, which one's
beta, which one's gamma.
There's four things, five
things you should [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
Now, the next thing
that I want to do
is to show you that the
two things that we looked
at about the liquid
gas transition--
in fact, one of them
implies the other.
So we said that
essentially by continuity,
when I look at the shape
of this critical isoterm,
it come down in this zero slope.
When, again, to continuously
join the type of curve
that I have for T greater
than TC of magnetization
and T less than
TC below, I should
have a curve that
comes and hogs the axis
or has infinite susceptibility.
I will show you that the
infinite susceptibility does,
in fact imply, that you must
have collective behavior.
That this critical
opalescence that we saw
is inseparable from
the fact that you
have diverging susceptibility.
I'll show that in the
case of the magnet.
But it also applies, of course,
to the critical opalescence.
So let's do a little
bit of thermodynamics.
So I can imagine if I have
some kind of Hamiltonia that
describes my interactions
among the spins in my argon
or any other magnet that I have.
And if I was to calculate
a partition function, what
I need to do would
be to trace over
all degrees of freedom
of this system.
Now, for the case of the
magnet, it is more convenient
actually to look at the ensemble
that is corresponding to this.
That is, fix the magnetic field
and allow the magnetization
to decide where it wants to be.
So I really want
to evaluate things
in this ensemble, which
really to be precise,
is not the [INAUDIBLE] ensemble,
but the Gibbs ensemble.
So this should be a
Gibbs free energy.
This should be a Gibbs
partition function.
But traditionally, most
texts including my notes
ignore that difference
and log of this.
Rather than calling
it G, we will call F.
But that doesn't
make much difference.
This clearly is a function
of temperature and H.
Now, if I wanted-- let's
imagine that always we
put the magnetic field
in one direction.
So I don't have to
worry for the time being
about vectorial aspect.
When you go back to
the vectorial aspect
later on, clearly--
actually this
is the net magnetization
of the system.
If I have a piece
of iron, it would
be the magnetization
of the entire iron.
And the average of
that magnetization,
given temperature
and field, et cetera,
I can obtain by taking
the log z by D beta H.
Because when I do that, I
go back inside the trace,
take a derivative in
respect to beta H.
And I have a trace of M into
the minus beta H plus beta HM,
which is how the different
probabilities are rated once
because of the log z.
In a derivative,
I have a 1 over z
to make this more properly
normalized probabilities.
So that's the standard story.
Now if I were to take
another derivative,
if I were to take
a derivative of M
with respect to H, which is
what the susceptibility is,
after all.
So the sensitivity
of the system--
there is the derivative
of magnetization
with respect to H.
It is the same thing
as beta derivative
of M with respect to
beta H, of course.
So I have to go to this
expression that I have on top
and take another derivative
with respect to beta H.
The derivative can act on beta
H that is in the numerator.
And what that does is it
essentially brings down
another factor of M. And
the Z is not touched.
Or I leave the
numerator as is and take
a derivative of the denominator.
And the derivative of
z I've already taken.
So essentially, because
it's in the denominator,
I will get the minus 1.
The derivative of 1 over z
will become 1 over z squared.
It will also give
me that fact factor
that multiplies
that factor itself.
So I have e to the minus
beta H plus beta HM.
And this whole
thing got squared.
OK?
So a very famous
formula-- always true.
Response functions such
as susceptibilities
are related to
variances-- in this case,
variance of the
net magnetization
of the system of course
true for other responses.
OK, this doesn't seem
to tell us very much.
But then I note the following
that-- OK, so I have my magnet.
What I have been asking is
what is the net magnetization
of piece of magnet and
its response to adding
a magnetic field.
If I want to think
more microscopically--
if I want to think,
go back in terms
of what we saw
for the liquid gas
system and the
critical opalescence
where there were fluctuations
in density all over the place,
I expect that the reality also
at some particular instance,
when I look at this,
there will be fluctuations
in magnetization
from one location
of the sample to another
location of the sample.
It's kind of building
gradually in the direction
of the statistical field.
I kind of expect to have these
long wavelength fluctuations.
And that's where I want to go.
But at this stage, I cannot
even worry about that.
I can say that I
define in whatever
way some kind of a
local magnetization
so that the net magnetization,
let's say in V dimension,
is the integrated version
of the local magnetization.
So magnetization
density I integrate
with the net magnetization.
OK, I put that over here.
I have two factors
of big M. So I
will get two factors of
integration over R and R prime.
Let's stick to three dimensions.
Doesn't matter.
We can generalize
it to be dimensions.
And here I have M
of R, M of R prime.
And average would
give me the average
of this M of R
minus M of R prime.
Whereas in the
second part, there
are the product of
two averages-- M
and R, average of M and R prime.
So it is the covariance.
So I basically have
to look at the M
at some point in my sample,
the M at some other point R
prime in the sample,
calculate the covariance.
Now, on average,
this piece of iron
doesn't know its left corner
from its right corner.
So just as in the
case of the lattice,
I expect once I do the
averaging, on average, M of R,
M of R prime should be only a
function of R minus R prime.
All right, so I expect
this covariance that's
indicated by MNC is really only
a function of the separation
between the two points, OK?
Which means that one
of these integrations
I can indeed perform.
There's the integral
with respect
to the relative coordinate and
the center of mass coordinate.
For getting boundary
dependence, this
will give you a factor of V.
There was a factor of beta
that I forgot.
There is an overall beta.
So I have chi beta.
And then I have the integral
over the relative coordinate
of the correlations
within two spins
in the system as a
function of separation.
Now, of course, like
any other quantity,
susceptibility is proportional
to how much material you have.
It's an extensive quantity.
So when I say that the
susceptibility diverges,
I really mean that
the susceptibility
per unit volume--
the intensive part
is the thing that will diverge.
But the susceptibility
per unit volume
is the result of doing an
integration of this covariance
as a function of position.
Let's see what we expect
this covariance to do.
So as a function
of separation, if I
look at the covariance
between two spins-- OK,
so there's this note
that I have already
subtracted out the average.
So whether you are in
the ferromagnetic phase
or in the paramagnetic
phase, the statement
is how much is the
fluctuation around the average
at this point and this
other point are related?
Well, when the two points come
together, what I'm looking
is some kind of a variance
of the randomness.
Now, when I go further
and further away,
I expect that
eventuality, what this
does as far as a fluctuation
around the averages
is concerned, does not influence
what is going on very far away.
So I expect that as a function
of going further and further
away, this is something
that will eventually
die off and go to zero.
Let's imagine that
there is some kind
of characteristic
landscape below which
the correlations
have died off to 0.
And I will say
that this integral
is less than or equal
to essentially looking
at the volume over which
there are correlations.
The correlations
within this volume
would typically be less
than sigma squared.
But let's bound it by sigma
squared times the volume
that we're dealing
with, which is either
four pi over 3c cubed.
Coefficients here
are not important.
OK, so if I know that
my response function
per unit volume, like
my compressibility
or susceptibility, if I
know that the left hand
side as I go to TC is diverging
and going to infinity,
variance is bounded.
I can't do anything with it.
Data is bounded.
I can't do anything with this.
The only thing that I
conclude, the only knob I have,
is that C must go to infinity.
So K over V going
to infinity implies
and is implied by
this [INAUDIBLE].
So I was actually
not quite truthful.
Because you need to
learn one other exponent.
So then how the
correlation then divergence
as a function of temperature
is also important
and is indicated by an
exponent that is called nu.
So C diverges as T to some
x point under this nu.
So this is what you were
seeing when I was showing you
the critical opalescence.
The size of these
fluctuations became so large
that you couldn't see
through the sample.
All kinds of wavelengths were
taking place in the system.
And if I had presented
things as square,
I could have given you
that as a prediction.
I should have shown you,
say, the critical isoterm
looks like this.
Therefore, if you
look at it at TC,
you shouldn't be able
to see through it.
This is [INAUDIBLE].
All right, so those
are the phenomena
that we would like
to now explain,
phenomena being these
critical exponent
alpha, beta, gamma, and nu,
et cetera, being universal
and the same across very
many different systems.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is [INAUDIBLE] in
elementary fundamental field
theory, like-- I mean,
like, in the standard model
or in quantum field theory where
something like this happens
where there's-- I mean, it's
not a thermodynamical system.
It's like elementary theory.
And yet--
PROFESSOR: Yep.
In some sense, the masses
of the different particles
are like correlation lengths.
Because it is the
mass of the particles
like in the nuclear
potential that
describes the range
of the interactions.
So there are phenomena
such as the case
of [INAUDIBLE] or whatever
where the range is infinite.
So in some sense,
those phenomena
are sitting at the
critical point.
OK, so the name of the
statistical field theory
that we will construct
is Landau Ginzburg
and originally constructed
by Landau in connection
to super fluidity.
But it can describe a lot of
different phase transitions.
Let's roughly introduce
it in the context
of these magnetic systems.
So basically, I have my magnet.
And again, in principle,
I have all kinds
of complicated
degrees of freedom
which are the spins that
have quantum mechanical
interactions, the exchange
interactions, whatever
the result of the
behavior of electrons
and their common
interactions with ions
is that eventually,
something like nickel becomes
a ferromagnet at
low temperatures.
Now, hopefully and actually
precisely in the context
that we are dealing
with, I don't
need to know any of
all those details.
I will just focus
on the phenomena
that there is a
system that undergoes
a transition between
ferromagnetic and paramagnetic
behavior and focus
on calculating
an appropriate partition
function for the degrees
of freedom that change their
behavior ongoing through TC.
So what I expect is
that again, just like we
saw for the case of
liquid gas system,
on one side for
the magnet, there
will be an average
zero magnetization
in the paramagnet.
But there will be
fluctuations of magnetization,
presumably with
long wavelengths.
On the other side, there
will be these fluctuations
on top of some average
magnetization that
has formed in the system.
And if I stick
sufficiently close to TC,
I expect that that
magnetization is small.
That's where the
exponent beta comes from.
So if I go sufficiently
close to TC,
these new Ms that I have
at each location hopefully
will not be very big.
So maybe in the same sense that
when I was doing elasticity
by going to low
temperature, I could
look at small deformations.
By sticking in the
vicinity of TC,
I can look at small
magnetization fluctuations.
So what I want to
do is to imagine
that within my system that
has lots and lots of electrons
and other microscopic
degrees of freedom,
I can focus on regions
that I average.
And with each region
that I average,
I associate magnetization
as a function
of position, which is
a statistical field
in the same sense
that displacement was.
See, over here, I will
write this quantity--
the analog of the
U-- in fact by using
two different vectorial
symbols for reasons
that will become obvious
shortly, hopefully.
Because I would like to have
the possibility of having
R to describe systems
that live in D dimensions
where D would be one if
I'm dealing with a wire.
D would be two if I'm
dealing with a flat plane.
D equals to three in
three dimensional space.
Maybe there's some relationship
to relativistic field theories
where we would be
four for space time.
But M I will allowed to
be something else that
has components M1, M2, Mn.
And we've already seen two
cases where n is either 1 or 3.
Clearly, if I'm thinking about
the case of a ferromagnet,
then there are three components
of the magnetization.
N has to three.
But then if I'm looking
at the analogous
thing for the liquid
gas system, the thing
that distinguishes
different locations
is the density--
density fluctuations.
And that's a scalar quantity.
So that corresponds
to N equals to 1.
There's other-- then we are
dealing with super fluidity
where what we are leaving it
is a quantum mechanical object
that has a phase
and an amplitude.
It has an x component-- real
and imaginary component that
corresponds to n equals to 2.
Again, n equals to 1
would describe something
like liquid gas.
N equals to 3 would correspond
to something like a magnet.
And there's actually no
relationship between n
and v. N could be larger than 3.
So imagine that you take a wire.
So x is clearly one-dimensional.
But along the wire, you
put three component spins.
So N could still be true.
So we can discuss a whole
bunch of different quantities
at the same time by generalizing
our picture of the magnet
to have n component and
existing D dimensions.
OK?
Now, the thing that I
would like to construct
is that I look at my system.
And I characterize it by
different configurations
of this field M of
R. And if I have
many examples of the same
system at the same temperature,
I will have different
realizations
of that statistical field.
I can assign the
different realizations
some kind of weight of
probability, if you like.
And what I would
like to do is to have
an idea of what the
weight of probability
of different configurations is.
Just because I have a background
in statistical mechanics,
in statistical mechanics, we
are used to [INAUDIBLE] weight.
So we take the log of
weight of probabilities
and call them some kind
of effective Hamiltonian.
And this effective
Hamiltonian is
distinct from a true
microscoping Hamiltonian
that describes the system.
And it's just a
way of describing
what the logarithm
of the probability
for the different
configurations is [INAUDIBLE].
Say, well, OK.
How do you go and
construct this?
Well, I say, OK.
Presumably, there is really some
true microscopic Hamiltonia.
And I can take whatever
that microscopic Hamiltonia
is that has all of my
degrees of freedom.
And then for a
particular configuration,
I know what the probability of
a true microscopic configuration
is.
Presumably, what I did
was to obtain my M of R
by somehow averaging over these
other two degrees of freedom.
So the construction to go
from the true microscopic
probabilities to
this effective weight
is just a change of variable.
I have to specify some
configuration M of R
in my system.
That configuration
of M of R will
be consistent with a huge number
of microscopic configurations.
I know what the
weight of each one
of those microscopic
configurations is.
I sum over all of them.
And I have this.
Now, of course, if
I could do that,
I would immediately
solve the full problem
and I wouldn't need to
have to deal with this.
Clearly, I can't do that.
But I can guess what the
eventual form of this
is in the same
way that I guessed
what the form of the statistical
field theory for elasticity
was just by looking at
symmetries and things
like that, OK?
So in principle, W from
change of variables starting
from into the minus beta H
in practice from symmetries
and a variety of other
statements and constraints
that I would tell you about.
Actually, let's keep this.
And let's illuminate this.
OK.
So there is beta H,
which is a function of M
as a function of this vector x.
First thing that
I will do is what
I did for the case
of elasticity, which
is to write the answer
as an integral in D
dimensions of some kind of
a density at location x.
So this is the same
locality type of constraint
that we were discussing before
and has some caveats associated
with that.
This is going to be a
function of the variable
at that location x.
So that's the field.
But I will also allow
various derivatives
to appear so that I go beyond
just single [INAUDIBLE]
will just give me
independent things happening
at each location by allowing
some kind of connections
in a neighborhood.
And if I go and recruit higher
and higher order derivatives,
naturally I would
have more pips.
Somebody was asking me--
you were asking me last time
in principle, if the
system is something
that varies from one
position to another position,
the very function itself
would depend on x.
But if we assume that
the system is uniform,
then we can drop that force.
So to be precise, let's do this
for the case of five 0 field.
Because when you are at
zero field in a magnet,
the different directions of
space are all the same to you.
There's no reason to be pointing
one direction as opposed
to another direction.
So because of this symmetry in
rotations, in this function,
you cannot have M-- actually,
you couldn't have M for other
reasons.
Well, OK.
You couldn't have M because it
would break the directionality.
But you could have
something that is M squared.
Again, to be precise, M
squared is some, let's say,
alpha running from 1 to n and
alpha of x and alpha of x.
Now, if the different directions
in space are the same,
then I can't have a
gradient appearing by itself
because it would pick
a particular direction.
In the same sense
that M squared,
two Ms have to be
appearing together,
if the different
directions in space
forward and backward are
to be treated the same,
I have to have gradients
appearing together
in powers of two.
So there's a term that,
before doing that,
let's say also sometimes
I will write something
that is M to the fourth.
M to the fourth is really
this quantity M dot M squared.
If I write M to the
sixth, it is M dot n.
Mute and so forth--
so there's all kinds
of terms such as that can
be appearing in this series.
Gradients-- there's a term
that I will write symbolically
as gradient of M square.
And by that, I mean to we
take a derivative of n alpha
with respect to
the alt component
and then repeat
the same thing sum
wrote over both alpha and alt.
So that would be the gradient.
So basically, the
xi appears twice.
M alpha appears twice.
And you can go and construct
higher and higher order terms
and derivatives, again
ensuring that each index
both on the side of the position
x and the side of the fields M
is a repeated index to
respect the symmetries that
are involved.
So if we-- there is actually
maybe one other thing
to think about, which
is that again like
before, I assume that I can make
an analytical expansion in M.
And who says you
are allowed to do
an analytical expansion in M?
Again, the key to
that is the averaging
that we have to
do in the process.
And I want you to think back
to the central limit theorem.
Let's imagine that there
is a variable x where
the probability of
selecting that variable x
is actually kind of singular.
Maybe it is something
like e to the minus x
that is a discontinuity.
Maybe it even has an integrable
divergence at some point.
Maybe it has additional
delta function.
All kinds of-- it's a very
complicated, singular type
of a function.
Now, I tell you-- add
thousands of these variables
together and tell me what the
distribution of the sum is.
And the distribution of the sum,
because of the central limit
theorem, you know
has to look Gaussian.
So then take its log, it has
a nice analytical expansion.
So the point is that
again, part of the course
grading that we did to get from
whatever microscopic degrees
of freedom that we
have, to reaching
the level of this
effective field theory,
we added many
variables together.
And because of the
central limit theorem,
I have a lot of confidence
that quite generically,
I can make an analytical
expansion such as this.
But I have not.
So having done all
of this, you would
say that in order to describe
this magnet, what we need
is to evaluate the
partition function,
let's say, as a
function of temperature,
which if I had
enormous power, I would
do by trace of into
the beta H microscopic.
But what I have done
is I have subdivided
different configurations of
microscopic degrees of freedom
to different configurations of
this effective magnetization.
And so essentially, that sum
is the same as integrating over
all configurations of this
constrained magnetization
field.
And the probabilities
of these configurations
of the magnetization field are
exponential of this minus data
H that I'm constructing
on the basis of principles
that I told you-- principles
where that I first of all
have a locality.
I have an integrality of x.
And then I have to
write terms that
are consistent
with the symmetry.
First term that we saw that is
consistent with the symmetry
is this M squared.
And let's give a name
to its coefficient.
Just like the coefficient of
elasticity, I put it nu over 2.
Let's get here a T over 2.
There will be
higher order terms.
There will be M to the fourth.
There will be M to the sixth.
There will be a whole bunch
of things in principle.
There will be gradient
types of terms.
So there will be K over
2, gradient of M squared.
There will be L over 2
Laplacian of M squared.
There would be higher
order terms that
involve multiplying M's
and various gradient
of M, et cetera.
And actually, in
principle, there
could be an overall constant.
So there could be up here
some overall constant
of integration-- let's call
it beta F0-- which depends
on temperature and so
forth but has nothing
to do with the ordering of these
magnetization type of degrees
of freedom.
Actually, if I imagine that I go
slightly away from the H equals
to 0 axis, just I did
before, I will add here
a term minus beta H of M and
evaluate this whole thing.
So this is the
Landau-Ginzberg theory.
In principle, you have to put
a lot of terms in the series.
Our task would be to
show you quite rigorously
that just a few
terms in the series
aren't enough just as in the
case of theory of vibration
for small enough vibration.
In this case, the analog
of small enough vibration
is to be close enough to
the critical point, exactly
where we want to calculate
these universal exponents
and to then calculate the
universal exponents, which
will turn out to
be a hard problem
that we will struggle with
in the next many lectures.